hi i'm joe coy and i'm playing truth or
share
on the kelly clarkson show wish me luck
oh that's easy um those are both
uh pretty creepy topics so i'm gonna say
what's the creepiest thing in my house
the creepiest thing
in my house is my cpap machine and the
only reason why
oh by the way if you don't know what a
cpap machine is i have sleep apnea
so i don't breathe at night and i'm also
a mouth breather
which means i breathe through my nose
and my mouth so i sleep like this
oh so i have to buy a special mask
that covers the entire face basically
like right
right around here from nose to chin
cover i look like
vein from batman i look like a villain
and i'm single so you know
it's not something you want to see on
the side of my bed
if it ever gets there you're going to
see a collection of face masks
and it almost looks like a serial killer
i'm not gonna lie it's creepy it even
creeps me out
no line
[Music]
all right so uh i think i'll show you my
last selfie which is actually a
pretty cool one it was with miss
clarkson
bye kelly my hunky dog
[Music]
the last thing that i lied to my son
about is that i stopped drinking
and i didn't get drunk this one night oh
first of all that didn't come out right
that makes me sound like i'm a drunk i'm
not drunk what i'm saying is
is uh i told my son i don't really go
out and have drinks with my friends
anymore
i just go have dinner lie i was hammered
and you know when i'm hammered because
i'm at that age now that when i drink
for the night
when i drink the next morning my ankles
swell up
so that's when you know someone's lying
someone has jameson in their feet
and that's me
all right my my last text to a fellow
comic
is my good friend chelsea handler and i
got my own coffee line right i made my
own coffee
and i made this little commercial and i
posted it and stuff and
uh and i go uh when i drink it i go oh
so delicious
right and then she put in the comments i
doubt it
right so then i i texted her
i go and i texted her this was sunday so
here's chelsea see it says chelsea
handler and i wrote
hey ass and then she wrote what and i
wrote
you're not helping me sell coffee by
saying probably doesn't taste delicious
jesus chelsea see so that's what he says
in the bubble
and then she responds like chelsea
fashion she goes
i'm supposed to help you sell copy
and then i just sent a picture of steve
harvey crying we just facetimed each
other and she's just like
dying laughing she loves it that's the
thing about chelsea
she loves it and i love her i'm joe coy
and that concludes my
portion of truth or share i hope you uh
learned a lot
about me um but watch me on the kelly
clarkson show
and of course my book my book comes out
march 23rd it's probably already out now
to be honest
so go get it now go to joey.com for the
barnes noble go to apple go to google
amazon doesn't matter the book is out
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help